en attendant de rejoindre l'union
européenne et de bénéficier pleinement
de ces aides mayotte se contente
aujourd'hui des dons octroyés par
bruxelles des millions d'euros dont des
inspecteurs sont chargés de suivre le
bon usage l'un d'entre eux vient
d'arriver à mamoudzou pour mayotte sur 5
ans et 10 millions d'euros qui seront
donnés ici à kong où paul chic un pas
affecté cinq cent mille euros à cette
structure une écloserie de poissons qui
rendra l'aquaculture mahoraise
indépendante si paul chicane vient bien
à mayotte pour donner des sommes énormes
pour le développement il vient aussi
contrôlé minutieusement
l'utilisation qui est faite de ces dons
c'est un don c'est pas des prêts
s'est donné en principe à mayotte
mayotte est peu nous est représentée par
les ordinateurs territoriale
l'ordonnateur territoriale est parfaite
dans le moment paul qui grimpe à visiter
mayotte aquaculture la seule société de
l'île exportatrices qui soit
complètement aux normes européennes une
société qui n'a bénéficié d'ailleurs
jusqu'à présent d'aucun soutien public
c'est l'union européenne qui va aussi
financer le futur centre d'enfouissement
des déchets et le réseau
d'assainissement de mamoudzou énorme
cela n'est rien à côté des sommes que
pourrait recevoir mayotte cl il faisait
partie intégrante de l'union européenne
comme la réunion l'accès aux fonds
structurels européens des fonds destinés
à mettre un territoire au niveau moyen
de l'europe ces fonds bouleverserait
complètement l'avis de mayotte pour
faire rentrer lille dans le monde
moderne bien ou mal oui ou non
réponse en 2010 et là ce seront les
mahorais qui décideront